a major moment in a long campaign in
1897 British soldiers stole thousands of
finely wrought artifacts like this from
the then Kingdom of Benin in modern-day
Nigeria now London's hornerman museum is
returning these six pieces and signing
over the ownership of the 66 other
so-called Benin bronzes in its
collection to enable these objects to be
displayed in museums for people to see
and people from outside the country to
come and see in the context of where
they have been looted is a significant
moment for us for now there are six
deliberate gaps in the Museum's display
cases more will follow with plans for a
significant number of artifacts to
remain on an extended loan from the
Nigerian government it is here at the
British museum where the largest single
collection of artifacts taken from Benin
remains more than 900 individual objects
the museum says it wants to share its
collection as widely as possible it
isn't though talking about returning
them one major stumbling block is
written into British law and 1963 Act of
parliament forbidding the Museum from
disposing of its exhibits with just a
few clearly defined exceptions in a
statement the museum emphasized its
collaborative work in Nigeria saying we
actively engage with Partners through
the Benin dialogue group and the digital
Benin initiative while research and
cultural exchange initiatives are also
key priorities but in recent years other
institutions in Scotland France Germany
and elsewhere have been returning items
from their Benin bronze collections
something Barnaby Phillips author of a
recent history of the bronzes says has
left the British museum increasingly
isolated remember that an institution
like the British museum is also under
pressure from other areas there's a
British government with its own interest
there are other significant National
museums in this country like the
Victorian Albert Museum the Royal
collection all of which might be I guess
you would say more conservatively
inclined and they too can exert their
pressure and influence on the British
museum over the years the debate has
taken in concerns over security and
conservation in Nigeria but increasingly
it's become one about Justice and
restoration Nigeria's cultural
custodians say it's time for British
institutions and British politicians to
write a historical wrong Harry Fawcett
Al Jazeera London